i'm proud of you for trusting your
instinct because i know that there has
has to be as there was in the case for
me a lot of people around you
who want to keep that train moving who
want you to keep going
and then only you know
only you know when it is time from one
iconic tv personality to another
oprah's got some words of wisdom for
ellen degeneres
as the comedian prepares to say goodbye
to her daytime talk show
they're just different things as a
creative person that i feel like
i need to do on wednesday ellen
announced that she's moving on from her
talk show which
first launched in 2003. it's september
8th this is our very very first show
and you are my very first audience
today i am announcing that next season
season 19
is going to be my last season how are
you gonna know when it's the right time
to walk away from daytime
um well i hope i know when when people
kind of are tired of me
i think i'll sense that i'll walk away
really when i when i stop having fun
on thursday ellen invited lady o onto
her show
to reflect on the past and look forward
to the future
what did you miss the most immediately
and then later and then what do you
think i'm gonna miss the most
well i think the camaraderie like you
were just just just
how you've changed people's lives and
the people on your staff and
what's happened in twitch's life i mean
you will still have those relationships
but what i missed the most was the
audience and i don't mean just
oh audience applause but i always felt
like i was a surrogate viewer and that i
was there
representing the audience so many times
i would ask questions particularly of
celebrities that i didn't care about the
answer
but i was the stand-in the surrogate for
the audience
so i really missed the camaraderie with
the audience because as you know after
every show i'd sit and i talked to the
audience and
that's where a lot of our ideas came
from oprah goes on to remind ellen that
the magic of an audience
isn't gone forever especially if she
continues with stand-up comedy
or other similar projects but
hilariously
oprah also revealed what she definitely
does not miss
i was doing a makeover show we were very
we did a lot of makeovers over the years
and i just thought there's not another
way i can ask somebody what mascara are
you wearing
there's not another way i can say what
color is that eye shadow
there wasn't another way i could do that
and be honest
authentic with myself and so i thought
yep time
time to start thinking about moving in
another direction also on thursday
et spoke with oprah's best friend cbs
this morning anchor gayle
king who shared why it was so touching
to see the two daytime tv icons together
i was told from reliable sources i was
told
she wanted oprah to be there when she
announced it
that that was going that this was going
to be her last year
and i thought that there was something
very nice about that the two of them
together
i thought that that was a nice thing the
journalist
also shares kind words about oprah and
ellen
and their lasting legacies when she said
she was going to call it quits
i didn't believe that she was actually
going to do it i did
i thought you you can't you'll miss it
it's too important but she said you
always have to know
when it's time to leave the party she
went out with a bang she went out with a
class act
she went out in um it was a very fitting
way that she ended that she went to the
oprah winfrey show
and listen ellen is not gone yet ellen's
not gone yet
another year and i'm excited about that